[Musica]
dove mi porta alla vostra mente se
pensate ad una cosa bella e dove invece
vi porta la vostra mente se pensate ad
una cosa buona
ognuno di noi assocerà un significato
diverso ad una cosa bella è una cosa
buona perché diversa e l'idea che ognuno
di noi sa di una cosa bella e di una
cosa buona ma ciò che a mio avviso è
davvero interessante scoprire e che la
sensazione che generano la bellezza e la
bontà sono pressoché comuni in ognuno di
noi
qual è la sensazione che genera la
bellezza di una cosa è un'emozione
positiva
un'emozione positiva quasi un benessere
interiore
pensiamo ad un'opera d'arte
questo in questo momento è quello che
viene da pensare se pensa di una cosa
bella
se invece pensiamo ad una cosa buona la
sensazione che genera una cosa buona è
una sensazione di fiducia di fiducia
nelle qualità intrinseca che questo
qualcosa
pensate ad un frutto un frutto buono che
cosa ci dice questa sensazione di
emozione positiva per la bellezza e di
sensazione di fiducia per un frutto
buono e che la bellezza così come nel
caso di un'opera d'arte
la bellezza di una cosa può essere anche
soltanto contemplata
mentre invece la bontà e quindi la
sensazione che genera una cosa buona
necessita di una cerca relazionalità
cioè noi abbiamo bisogno di assaporare
il frutto
per poter avere soddisfatta la
sensazione di fiducia nelle sue qualità
intrinseca quindi potremmo dire che la
realtà delle cose è il frutto di
significati rappresentazioni e di
sensazioni nel caso della bellezza
un'emozione positiva nel caso della
bontà può essere questa sensazione di
fiducia
ora pensiamo alla bellezza e la bontà
collegata alle persone se vi chiedessi
che chi è una persona bella e chi è una
persona buona
una persona bella è una persona unica
una persona diversa perché unica perché
ha una sua storia una persona buona
è una persona che rilascia così come nel
caso del frutto una sensazione di
fiducia fiducia nelle qualità intrinseca
anche una persona bella può essere
semplicemente osservata è contemplata ma
c'è bisogno di qualcuno che sappia
coglierne la bellezza la persona havona
ha necessità di entrare in relazione con
gli altri per poter dispiegare quella
sensazione di fiducia cayman emana
quindi fiducia nelle proprie qualità
quindi potremmo sintetizzare dire che la
realtà delle persone è il risultato di
significato rappresentazione sensazioni
e soprattutto di capacità cioè la
capacità di saper cogliere la bellezza e
la capacità di sapersi relazionare con
gli altri ora proviamo a trasporre tutto
questo discorso in un ambiente
lavorativo multiculturale
non sarà facile
anzi non sarà difficile comprendere che
avremo delle persone diverse
culturalmente uniche per questo è dunque
belle secondo l'accezione che abbiamo
raccontato prima ma le persone belle e
unica diverse dal punto di vista
culturale hanno necessità di qualcuno
che le sappia comprendere di qualcuno
che sappia fatte a leggere l'unicità
delle loro storie
quindi c'è bisogno di un leader che
abbia tale capacità abbia la capacità di
comprendere la diversità culturale la
bellezza della diversità culturale e
abbia anche la capacità di saper inter
di di entrare in relazione con questa
diversità culturale
quindi in un ambiente culturale o meglio
un ambiente lavorativo multiculturale la
realtà è fatta di significati
rappresentazioni sensazioni ricordate
sempre quella delle emozione positiva e
della sensazione di fiducia è necessario
che ci sia anche la capacità di un
leader che sappia riconoscere ed entrare
in relazione con questa diversità ma se
io adesso vi chiedessi quella è la
maggiore qualità di un leader così come
le capacità di cui abbiamo parlato prima
e la competenza e allora sarà facile
arrivare al discorso che un leader
competente in ambiente multiculturale è
colui che sa prima di ogni cosa a
rilevare l'unicità delle storie delle
persone delle persone che hanno una
cultura diversa e soprattutto che sa
entrare relazione con tale diversità
quindi ripeto con questa unicità delle
storie quindi leader buono elide
competente
ora se tutto questo è vero
e quindi se tutto questo è vero che
abbiamo significati rappresentazioni
sensazioni capacità è anche vero che oli
del buono deve avere la capacità di
saper condividere con un linguaggio
positivo
tutto questo perché noi potremmo avere
semplicemente rappresentazioni potremmo
avere un uguale sensazione ma abbiamo
necessità di dover cercare di avere uno
stesso linguaggio positivo ad esempio se
noi parliamo di distanza culturale ci
accorgeremmo che ci crea una sensazione
di frizione nell'interazione con gli
altri se invece noi parliamo di
diversità culturale e quindi il
linguaggio ha un senso particolare
diventerà meno difficile interagire con
gli altri
se noi parliamo di creazione di ponti
tra due culture piuttosto che di analisi
delle differenze e quindi fondiamo il
nostro ragionamento sulla similarità
nelle storie che per se stesse sono
unica
molto probabilmente riusciremo a creare
quello ambiente lavorativo
multiculturale che genera quell emozione
positiva e quella sensazione di fiducia
ora i pilastri a mio modo di vedere per
l'esperienza di studio che ed
interazione che ho avuto nel percorso
della mia vita mi portano a dire che i
pilastri delle relazioni interculturali
che ameremo dire noi è i miei studenti
cross cultural si fondano stanzialmente
su due punti la forza di quella che la
letteratura chiama la consapevolezza
culturale cioè saper distinguere se
stessi dagli altri e saper distinguere
la propria unicità da quella degli altri
e saper interagire tra queste due unici
che l'altro pilastro fondamentale è
l'approccio positivo e la diversità
culturale per cui abbiamo da un lato la
forza della consapevolezza culturale
e abbiamo anche il valore di un
approccio positivo alla diversità
questo perché è nato in me perché io ho
tanta voglia di comunicarvelo ve lo
racconterò utilizzando le onde del
nostro te da queste onde sono state per
me fondamentali perché hanno ingenerato
dapprima una sensazione uno stato
confusionale e poi uno stato nuovo che
amo dire un nuovo stato mentale nel 1998
quando ancora era aveva appena terminato
gli esami e cominciai a lavorare con mio
padre
pensai siamo troppo diversi
davvero il mio concetto di diversità è
cominciato in una stesso ambiente
culturale nell'impresa cara l'impresa di
famiglia ed eravamo così diversi per me
allora fu chiaro che la differenza era
una differenza in sistemi di credenze ma
eravamo unici mio padre era un uomo di
successo ma io non ci potevo lavorare
noi non riuscivamo a comunicare e io non
avevo ancora la capacità di saper
comunicare con la sua unicità questo
stato confusionale al quale aggiungere
nel 2005 le parole di mio figlio è qui
presente e mi fece questa domanda aveva
tre anni e mezzo e mi disse mamma
qual è la differenza tra uguale simile
identico siccome è possibile che un
bambino innocente si chiede cosa possa
essere la similarità quindi forse è più
facile parlare di similarità piuttosto
che di differenza
ed è stato proprio in quell'anno che ho
pubblicato il mio primo libro che era
sulle dissonanze culturali perché
proprio ancora mi rigiravo di parlare
già allora mi rifiutavo di parlare di
differenze di differenze culturali e
parlavo di questa dissonanza di questa
incapacità di comprendere
la mia seconda honda arriva quando
confusa dalla letteratura perché
continuate continuava a studiare nel
2009 2009 continuava a raccontarmi che
cosa è questa analisi questa prospettiva
della comparazione delle culture nel
management e incomincia a fare una
revisione approfondita della letteratura
mi resi conto che c'era un mosaico di
parole e concetti che andavano scoperto
e così nel 2012 pubblico il mio secondo
libro il cross cultural management come
un mosaico di parole e concetti dove in
realtà si raccontava di questa diversità
così come concepita nel mondo c'erano
ben cinque decadi di studiosi di
management che si avvicendavano a
spiegare cosa fosse la diversità e come
dovesse essere analizzata e noi qui non
avevamo ancora lui mesi di salerno un
insegnamento sul crowe e scaltro al
manager già sulla gestione delle
relazioni interculturali
finalmente inizia ad insegnare x
scatterà il management e l'università di
salerno e ed eravamo solo 4 in italia
però un certo punto c'era questa forza
della consapevolezza culturale che ormai
era snodata i miei studenti la
commissione già c'era questo questa
voglia di dover ancora conoscere arriva
questa ulteriore honda e decide di
partire per gli stati uniti perché
dovevo conoscere un certo richard
griffiths era il direttore esecutivo di
un centro l'unico che esisteva in
america e in europa non ce n'erano
sull'analisi del e che sono analisi e le
differenze culturali era sulla
competenza cross culturale ed è stato lì
che mi ha insegnato e con mia grande
sorpresa mi è stata data una fellowship
su come eccezionale capacità divide ci
pensi ma qualcosa significa significava
che la competenza cresca tra di un
leader forse connaturata alcuni
attributi naturali delle persone può
essere divulgata può essere di
e fu lì che arrivò questo stato nuovo
mentale e pensai ok
occorre inoltre insegnamento per cui
oggi se cresca altro il management e
crow scatto dal competence che crea le
basi primarie della consapevolezza
culturale forza della consapevolezza
culturale valore di un linguaggio
positivo
mancava qualcosa mancava la capacità di
passare all'azione mancava la diffusione
avevo bisogno di un luogo fisico mentale
e poi fisico per poter comunicare a
tutti questa ed è stato così che nel
2017 è nato un laboratorio di ricerca su
la diffusione della bellezza della
diversità e della bontà di un leader di
un manager si scoraggi un imprenditore
soprattutto di quelli che dovrebbero
essere gli imprenditori il manager i
policy makers del futuro i miei studenti
di come i perché di lì o la volontà di
sentirli come me perché noi lavoriamo e
sorridiamo di un linguaggio positivo
utilizziamo ponti e utilizziamo
opportunità quando parliamo di diversità
culturale perché la missione del crisi
lab è diffondere questo la bellezza
della diversità culturale e la bontà del
leader inteso come competente perché noi
abbiamo una grossa convinzione crediamo
fondamentalmente in quello che un
sociologo americano nel 1948 definiva
nelle scienze sociali come la profezia
che si auto la tempia
noi siamo convinti che parlare di
bellezza della diversità culturale nel
modo in cui noi viviamo una certa
accezione un'idea una rappresentazione
una sensazione quindi un'emozione
positiva e parlare di bontade
ed è leader nella fattispecie come
qualcuno che è competente e può imparare
ad essere competente nella relazione con
gli altri possa auto adempiervi per il
sol fatto di essere diffusa è raccontata
a tutti la nostra missione e raccontare
della bellezza della diversità e della
volontà di un manager
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]